all of this nonsense it's leaking into  our military this is the u.s navy i'm a  sailor i sail training its staff to  create a safe space by using gender  pronouns and i use chi her pronouns and  we're here to talk about pronouns using  the right pronouns is a really simple  way to affirm someone's identity what  happens to the marines another way that  we could show that we're allies and that  we accept  everybody is to maybe include our  pronouns in our emails or like we just  did introduce ourselves using our  pronouns that is so helpful the navy is  proud to honor you with this reward  some names are very difficult to  pronounce but do you know what is very  easy to pronounce she he they there  seems to be no sign of intelligent life  anywhere there is collective brain  damage happening across the world right  now oh thank you for telling me that  let's be clear she he them are [ __ ]  bananas